let's go let's just quickly figure out I
was just so so they will come to the
working yarn okay x equals negative a
quarter thumbs up yeah happy even though
it does will complete its negative
fractures however when we have a look at
what you've got on this the original
question besides I think we kind of
she'll expect a fraction not sure it is
but whereas if there's a messy looking
fraction to begin with so I'm not that
surprised that you end up would want to
be within the working looks like a kiss
kappa me nicely so I think we'll just
let that once a question to 57 degrees
yeah sure okay and I go questions before
about our about this now the cotton or
your calculator button on your
calculator I think it looks like that
doesn't it right cause it looks like to
the power 11 now most people would like
this most people would probably say and
just what you're working on icons on
your angle I needed the night yes they
are equals this is your first line to
end up as you intended to prevent you
from there I think most people would
just go straight to the top and backs
fun what do they mean is why I we sort
of like blumenstein it exists is that
this thing we call it an inverse trig
functions we can't learn how to use it
for basic purposes but there are lots of
fancy other things and we have to worry
about a little bit like that on the mode
on your calculator that mean you have to
be actually very careful whenever you
write this you guys will get my
confidence ever and if you want to put
that into sitting here kick is up what
am i doing my calculator that's fine but
if you want to know a little more about
why we have right we exercise caution
with that then tossing around Puget
Sound agreed then check is a series
middle of it okay now the last one
before we comes into working 186 poor
only four square centimeters looking
good
yeah yeah yeah I 185 pretty fun
incredibly okay boys it's like white
6000k right telstra second division yeah
so where where did these like minor
differences creep in and I'll show you
where they creep it they run on the
board how they look at the way that this
was worked out you can see every time
you go through like all of these
different ones there's kind of decimal
places hiding behind everything right
this is very common when you have a look
at tree and being angles they all seem
pleased you read decimal it goes forever
okay but when you're putting things into
the calculator for your warm up the
football that within and that's you
you're fine but what that will do is it
will lead to tiny little discrepancies
like point2 of a trench centimeter or
even even a little bit more because
there was a lot of very fine yeah but
some people got if you think about one
square centimeter in the scheme of this
is less than 12 set it's a very small
difference okay so that's why slightly
little changes in your decimals will
then turn passenger now we have
widespread agreement on this is a
slightly quicker way to get this same
answer it's fine to do it this way but
it does cost a little bit time there's
two main steps tree and then what's
going on here this is pepperoni okay in
there a way we can avoid photography
okay so yeah so back up a little bit
remember I said I'm read the question
really carefully being asked for area
the binary triangle you need to do you
need base and you need time you already
have you already have it's like behind
there is one of it so if there is a way
that's possible and this is what we kind
of learned yesterday your everyone we're
looking at weird various pressures and
we will all most of us we're taking the
long way round
the most important time just like when
you're doing an essay right most
important time in an essay is the
planning time and the most important
time to solve your question is when you
work out what part shall I teach through
we can have the amount of work that we
took even if we get the same impact if
we want to go straight to this space
don't be i'll quality of the baby what
am I going to do what am I going to do
differently can't come any class degree
yeah good so I'm going to different
ratios because these two guys are
opposite and adjacent once you've got
this size you can rule you can run
purpose you will still get 37 42 at
whatever and vehicle to area you happy
that